all right karina karina
where'd you grow up where are you from
i'm from mexico oh really
yes and you came to the us at what age
two
and uh tell me about your parents you
had both your parents in your life
yeah i do yeah yeah
good childhood good childhood
no what kind of stuff went on
like they were like they're worried
about money
and that's it and that's all yeah and
it's still the same way
that's why i left
they fight for money there's
like i don't know it's just i'm glad i'm
not there no more
and you went on your own at what age um
thirteen thirteen that's early
yeah i wasn't tired your parents were
thirteen huh why'd you leave your
parents at 13
because i was tired of them not being
the parents
i was like i'm tired they didn't let me
go out like
nowhere if i go to the door they'd be
like where are you going just get in
your room and
they always like i don't know it was
only about them
they were very selfish and they still
are
so what'd you do with your life from 13
on did you finish high school
no did you go to high school
yeah so so
today you're living on skid row yeah but
when i when i came over here how'd you
get down here
oh my god it's a long story well i'm
gonna make it a little short okay
um i met this man that he was the normal
man
before he did crystal meth now he's
cuckoo
and he i met him and he used to be my
ass and used to
like like abuse me for my baby
stuff like that so i got tired of it and
i was in la habra
and i got tired and i left when i left
i came over here but i was i think it
was i think this
this thing happened because because this
karma because like
i was at church and i was trying to get
a ride to get down here
like around twelve o'clock or one
o'clock in the like in the
night time and then i went to church
and i tell this lady at church can you
hug my baby because i wanted to take a
line
so i went to the bathroom and i did i
took a line you know
and then when i came over here i didn't
knew they had to drug test me
to for me to stay there i had to give
them a drug test but i barely took a
line
so so i opened my [ __ ] mouth and i
told this lady they work right there you
know what um
well yeah i'm dirty on meth that's why i
don't want to take my tests
and boom they open up
what you call the what you call that
thing the seat
child protective services yeah you got
it and then they
they took my son away because they
put it as a positive and then then
then the good start is coming then i
kept okay now i'm here down
here and then i'm i was an alcoholic i
used to drink a lot
i used to be an alcoholic for real like
number one alcoholic
but then i got here and i met
sharkey and when i met sharky
i don't know what the [ __ ] happened i
don't know i don't know i don't know
i don't know but it's weird okay i can't
drink no more
i hate alcohol i've been clean for 11
months
almost because of sharky he told me if
you want to get
drunk go to the corner and go with those
drunkens and get drunk
because you making me broke
and then and then i stop and then i stop
and then now i wanna
i don't wanna drink it's like disgusting
that oh and then another little story
i'm gonna
put in that one and then
i wanted to get pregnant by sharking i
used to get mad at him like
god sharky you don't come inside of me
damn it
he goes again again and guess what
happened
boom a baby in my stomach now so now i'm
four months pregnant
and i'm gonna have a baby another sharky
congratulations so are are you using
currently
crystal meth well i am trying my best
to not use it but it's the worst is of
the worst
i'm fighting it so bad it's very hard
it's gotta be a bad thing for the baby
but you know what i'm gonna make it
and i know i'm gonna go through this and
i'm gonna have my baby and
i'm gonna i'm gonna be all right what
are you waiting for
what are you waiting for what are you
waiting for are you four months in
it's only well i'm waiting for five
months you know and then i'm gonna have
my baby
but besides that i have another problem
and
on top of that i have a baby in the
system
he's two and
it's very hard oh my god i don't know i
don't know sometimes i feel like i'm not
gonna make it
you feel like white i feel like crying
everybody cries here i got kleenex
what's the worst part of losing your kid
do you ever see him
yeah i see him every wednesday
he's he was so attached to me like
i just feel like i'm not gonna make it
like i feel like they're gonna take both
of the babies away
if i don't do this for real if i don't
take
this serious you know
in reality i'm not taking it serious
right now and i have to
i have to take it serious because
because i know if i lose this baby and i
lose the other baby he ain't gonna [ __ ]
with me nobody's gonna [ __ ] with me
they're gonna be let down
look at that girl you know like shh
huh how old are you 35 35.
look in this neighborhood there's people
who are 45 55 65 they're still down here
yeah and you know what it's very hard
i've been brave before and stuff like
that and i made it
and i don't cry no more for that because
i i i will never
i'll i forgive him already but whenever
forget that but
i don't cry no more it doesn't faze me
no more it just went away already like
i don't think about that no more what i
heard me right now the most is hurting
me right now
is that i cannot leave the stuff alone
like
the party like i want to still party but
i want to have my baby
but i feel like i can i'm not going to
make it like
sometimes i feel like i'm not going to
make it
but i pray every day every day i pray to
god because i know he
he got my back and when i walk around
with him
and we walk around and we go do our
things
i'm talking to myself but i'm talking to
god and telling god
okay he needs to change my mind and my
brain and my soul and everything in a
different way i need to be a better mom
i got six kids you have six kids i have
six kids did you raise any of them
no i had never been a mom
i was being a drunky alcoholic
and then i met sharky and then
everything went i've been clean for 11
months so
and you know it was not hard clean from
alcohol though
not meth not not meth no that's but from
alcohol yeah
i'm i'm being clean very clean and
it doesn't face me you can't drink in
front of me and i feel like
okay you drink that [ __ ] that's what and
it's amazing
if i go back to my old friends in
gardena because that's my half half my
life i
i was raised over there and then my
other half in san diego
and if i go back to gardena and they're
not going to believe it
they i was a drunken and outside in the
liquor store
just waiting for a takabaka there's
those
half a pint and it sounds to me like you
traded alcohol for a mat
yes i did and that time i did yeah so
i'm not sure one is better than the
other
yeah they're both going to be bad for
your baby
they're both bad for me yeah and and
i mean there's more things that i want
to talk but i don't know if i should
say it because it's like too much it's
too
i just want to say something i just want
to say that
whoever messing around with that fennel
[ __ ] fat no whatever how you call that
crap
you [ __ ] preparing your own grave
and it's not fun doesn't my son told me
mom that's not a party drug like oh
we're gonna party uh
no it's not it's a drug that comes to
kill us
china made that drug to kill us and
that's what they're doing
and i was like wow like and it gets into
my head
but it doesn't get into my head it's
it's just crazy
but it's scary like it's very scary very
scary and
i have bad dreams with with that stuff
it was very good you tried fentanyl too
yeah i did try it and it was
horrible when i wanted to got out of it
i went seven days
cold turkey and it was the most horrible
feeling in my life
that was the more anxiety i never had in
my life i had a that those seven days
and it was horrible what do you what is
stopping you from
quitting all together everything
they either i'm gonna i'm gonna end
killing my baby and i'm gonna be alive
and going to jail for the rest of my
life
no what what's because what's blocking
you from stopping
drugs
the environment that i'm with like
yeah you're in skid row where everyone's
doing drugs yeah yeah the environment
the people around me that are still
doing and if they do it
if i want to do it too because i i'm
very like
um impulsive um very weak minded
like i'm very easy to be like oh
[ __ ] i want to hit i can't say no
then you got to get out of here yeah i
think that would be the best thing for
me but
i don't want to leave sharky
it's kind of hard for me it's hard you
know what before i used to cry a lot i
used to be crying for everything that
happened in my life
but now i don't now i don't you know
what now
you know what it's it's it's hard to to
forget like my mom
my mom when she's i used to be little my
mom never unders never been a mom like
she never understand
um to like understand to talk to me like
mom i wanna know about my period
oh i don't wanna oh we don't talk about
that [ __ ] right here
um i got molested when i was young when
i was eight
and and i went and told my mom that
somebody did this to me and she didn't
believe me she said
um you liked that you wanted that to
happen to you and she grabbed the bell
and i would
never forget that she hit me so hard
like
oh my god so hard until she was sweating
and i was like i was [ __ ] up like you
should have done that hit to that guy
like
you hit me like that's crazy and then
she used to be very
i mean i already forgive her about this
[ __ ] man i already did but
she used to be very respectful to me and
my my brother like she used to have like
like no sex with my dad and didn't
stay quiet or knowing that we're like
next door like we don't have a window
and you i mean you can see
so i will be the one that used to work
up and i'll be like [ __ ] man this
[ __ ] don't stop
so i used to be angry at them and the
next following day i used to tell them
well you ain't gonna take a shower or
what and then i used to tell my dad the
same thing and
i think all that [ __ ] that's why i
i i feel so um how can i tell you like
um like i used to be in this when i was
10 i used to be very
chunky okay and then my mom used to like
call me like names like
like throw this free wheelie coming
walking over here and
like oh if i was if i were to look like
you i would
get a gun and [ __ ] in my head and stuff
like that
i got into my head so now i feel like my
self-esteem is like on the floor
like do you understand yeah it's a
common story i think
yeah a lot of people go through that
kind of childhood stuff and it
impacts their life forever yeah so now
it's in my head so when i try meth
and i got very skinny that was like whoa
now i know how to lose weight fast now
i'm gonna look like i wanna look
but i was looking horrible i was looking
horrible like an old lady
and you should have seen me when i
finished doing that stupid friend i went
to the
to the place where i stayed like this
homeless place
i went in the bathroom and i'm being
freaking serious
you look like a straight out demon i
went and i looked at myself and i was
like
what the [ __ ] are you serious karina my
bone like sticking out my face was like
i said [ __ ] i look like a straight up
demon like a
[ __ ] demon that [ __ ] is really
preparing you to go to
[ __ ] hell you making you so skinny
and preparing your grave to go so you
can take the last little hair that
you're gonna and you're
done and when i went there i was like
no wonder me and sharky were fighting so
much like look at me like
i'm [ __ ] like so talked out like so
druggy like so smoked out i look so
nasty and this these people that
used to talk to me before when i used to
complain about my fat
and fat i told them look oh you lost a
lot of weight and i said i do
i look alright i look like a demon and
then
she goes but you want to be skinny god
don't want you skinny girl
god god wants you how you are
and if you want to be somebody else this
is how you're going to look and this is
how you're going to look by doing it
that kind of way
like doing drugs you could do a doing
exercise
you always want to do it the easy way
and it's not the easy way
because the easy way is a bad way so
many people play around with these drugs
for weight loss reasons you think yeah
to be honest like if you if you ask all
these girls
why you use math always
they don't want to like don't deny like
they don't accept it but
i i do like i i i want to lose weight
when i sing that [ __ ] i say oh no this
is my [ __ ] i'm gonna stay in this [ __ ]
is that how it started for you just
trying to
lose weight is that how it started yeah
because look when i stop
and i start gaining weight i'm busted it
like oh
[ __ ] i look disgusted [ __ ] i need to
[ __ ] mess
and then i'll do it again and i'll lose
it again and then that's how i'm
and i can't ask if i stop it's oh i look
like a [ __ ] pig
it's crazy it's i'm like you see
everything comes from the past you see
everything how clicks from the past my
mom calling me name
and it ended ended right like this just
like this
me doing drugs because i felt like i was
fat ugly whatever
because in my house there was no love
there was nothing they were just
fighting for their money and their
business and
they still [ __ ] are i think they are
because my kids are all [ __ ] up
my kids are all bad my son is in a
[ __ ] program because he does
um injects himself with i don't know how
you call that [ __ ] but
it's some shitty you put black clean
some [ __ ] in your arm
he's only 17 and he's [ __ ] addicted
to the [ __ ] he's in a program right now
but he looks so different now
that he's clean he's been clean for six
months my other son is over there
selling dope smoking fentanyl
stuck on fentanyl and selling fentanyl
and
acid pills and all kinds of [ __ ] at my
mom's house they already hit my mom
so many [ __ ] times but and they'll
when i go over there they'll be like
what are you doing here [ __ ] like they
say bad words soon like
and i probably i i you know probably i
don't know maybe i deserve them i don't
know but
but they're very bad my kids are very
two of my kids are cutters i don't know
if you know about cutters but
they [ __ ] with the devil and the two of
my kids are doing that bush
i go to mom's house and the only thing
you hear is a [ __ ] devil's music
in my mom's rooms it's crazy i seen them
cut themselves with knives
i was like and i was high on mess i was
[ __ ] high in men
and i used to be tweaking on it because
these were these [ __ ]
i used to lock my room because i feel
like they were going to kill me
[ __ ] hearing
demo music the ouija board and they're
[ __ ] cutting them my [ __ ] are
going to end killing my ass
for leaving them alone and my mom get on
them that was going to happen
and i used to get like paranoid you know
my kid what are you doing what are you
doing in the bathroom
well there's blood everywhere what the
[ __ ] are you guys doing
and nothing nothing and then i will go
and find the nice little blurry what the
[ __ ] is what you guys
do you guys cut themselves you guys are
stupid as [ __ ]
who the [ __ ] does that you guys are not
normal
that is not normal who the [ __ ] cuts
himself with the knife
for for pain so we relieve the pain
[ __ ] you have more pain like
that
relieve the pain for i don't believe
that [ __ ] the [ __ ] are you made of what
do you understand so i have a lot of
problems
but the good good thing in the good part
about me right now
is that i met this man and
he's a good man but he he kind of lost
like 50 points already he had a hundred
but he lost 50. and he needs to get him
back
and he eat and i don't know he's a good
man but he has ratchet
fletching moves you know like
he's still got ratchet moves like
like a little homeless yeah
i have a lot of problems i have a lot of
problems with that but
he's the best man i ever have because
he's been there
and he showed me not to be a scary [ __ ]
you know i'm almost killing [ __ ] i
don't play
because he showed me that so now i'm
doing what he showed me so you're living
on a skid row if you have a baby in five
months
no we're gonna get an apartment i don't
give a [ __ ] how we gonna do it we got
five months to do this and we gotta do
it no matter what
how we get the pookie and the thing
that's how we're going to get the
apartment
that's how it goes and then and we have
to we it's just
either or you want your baby to because
for real as soon as they come out and
the baby doesn't have nowhere to go
they're going to get
them and they're going to get in they
get them easy they can just
somebody could get them so easy because
he's so little
it's like oh it's very little and then
it's very easy for somebody to get that
baby
you know and i already have a uh open
case
with my other son is is very very hard
so if i don't show him that i'm okay
that i have a [ __ ] job and i have
apartment and i have everything
and i finish my program in those months
that they told me because i'm very
blessed
for this corona virus going on and [ __ ]
people up but they [ __ ]
they helped me in some way because they
were about to take my rights as a mother
on on march and because of this [ __ ]
happened they [ __ ] said they gave me
eight more months to
finish my program and get my baby back
so now it's
it's on me now yeah you understand i do
so so it's on me now so a little bit i
better get my ass and that's the way i
get
get my you know my little things and i
can get my baby
back i like to party then i have to be
responsible
and i'm not and i have to learn
all right karina well thank you for
sharing your story and good luck with
your baby
yeah maybe when i have the baby i'll
come back and i'll do a
feminine interview i hope you get it all
i hope you get clean and get your
act together between now and then i will
maybe yeah that's gonna be a promise i'm
gonna come back with my babies and i'm
gonna do an interview
excellent that'll be a good one thank
you okay
now we're done
you